[Musique]
je suis allemande je l'aï mis les haines
mauricienne espagnol et anglais il
regretté
pensez vous que les français aiment les
étrangers oui je crois non je ne crois
pas mon impression est que les français
sont très très méfiant des étrangers je
n'ai jamais eu à
rencontrer des comportements
désagréables j'ai quand même entendu des
réflexions plus tôt déplaisante sont-ils
gay les français oui oui je crois
pas trop
il ya trop de sérieux
sur le réalisme
je ne crois pas ils sont plutôt ironique
et l'ironie suppose une certaine acidité
pas tout à fait de la gaieté gay oui
mais une gaieté plutôt mp légère oui
sont toujours en train de rire oui à
saly pas là pour l'amour parce que nous
on est un peu très posé en face et
honteux de rire et tout ça oui à côté du
futur côté le japonais oui ils sont
assez décontracté
[Musique]
parce que les français sont des gens
polis
[Musique]
oui mais je pense que cette politesse
c'est plutôt formel un peu extérieur
qu'elle est moins profonde que la
politesse anglaise par exemple enfin en
tout cas ils évitent toujours de ce que
les gens vont ils sont ils ont les
apparences sociale et surtout le
comportement social dans la foule de
gens volent ils vous bousculent pas
c'est le monde à tous les pays qu'ils y
croyaient
c'est le monde puisse juger utile bien
élevé il dit tout de suite pardo merci
sur la surface des fois oui mais à faux
pas du tout ce qui me choquait au début
quand j'étais en france c'était
la bousculade tout le temps dans les
rues dans le métro les gens
on vous claque la porte devant
l'importance quand je suis dans le métro
je suis bousculé en dans le groupe y est
presque ses
serveurs ea table qu'il se tienne bien
oui je t'aime bien mais sur un marquis
qui les trompent tout dans son café
sachets charles viendra il trompe le
crois ça le pas c'était bouton
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
galanterie française
ça n'existe pas
je crois qu'elle a un peu disparu
ont trouvé plus de la galanterie on se
dise tu aurais je crois toujours pas
dans la vie je la trouve par moments un
peu servile et un peu intéressé sur
préfère l'éducation japonaise pour les
femmes que
mais pour les françaises les hommes sont
alors les fans il respecte la femme
parce qu'il est
quelquefois c'est un peu trop
[Musique]
que ce qui caractérise de plus de près
vous l'attitude des français vis-à-vis
des femmes
ils sont évidemment coureurs il
baratinage il donnait pas avoir qui
centralise ça les femmes main derrière
ils s'intéressent beaucoup ils sont très
expressive ils sont gentils sont
européens ne sais pas c'est un esprit
assez libre de gentillesse et
enfin beaucoup d'urbanité
une certaine soumission inconsciente
peut-être long mais c'est pour hier j'ai
l'impression et les femmes comme simple
peut elle regarde son mari
pensez vous que les français sont de
bons maris je ne sais pas il me semble
que dans le ménage français que je
connais du moins
enfin il ya une collaboration
je n'ai pas tellement rencontrer deux de
couple à dominante masculine ou féminine
tous les filles et les femmes des
icaunais ils sont tous divorcés et ils
sont tous séparés ont même essayé
ensemble est
évident invite c'est pareil ils sont
tous les deux se tient là son côté je
pense que les rapports entre mari et
femme sont des rappeurs
beaucoup plus de camaraderie
[Musique]
vous pensez qu'ils sont fidèles
oui je crois je crois quand même surpris
parce que je connais
pense pas non pas outre mesure
en norvège les français en
interprétation pour être instruits
infidèle
pourquoi parce que les femmes françaises
sont fidèles
[Musique]
ce que les français élèves bien leurs
infos
infiniment mieux que
dans tout le pays où j'étais je crois
qu'ils les élèves un peu
un peu au hasard et ce qui me frappe le
plus c'est les femmes montant dans le
métro avec deux ou trois gosses qui
prendre un siège pour chaque gosse quand
les vieilles dames sont debout ça elles
sont un peu trop gâté là les frappes
trop
toujours toujours dans le bas ou comme
ça
ça me paraît fort c'est pas tellement
enfin ça c'est un problème
général
au monde occidental contemporain c'est à
dire par rapport quand même aux gosses
américains que j'ai connu
c'est nettement mieux
[Musique]
dans leur maison à ce que les français
ont le sens du confort
oui surtout le sens de la
personnalisation du confort du de
l'aménagement du bricolage c'est
admirable en france les maisons retaper
on trouve très rarement le vrai confort
dans les appartements français très peu
cela me semble incroyable que les
français tiennent extraordinairement à
sa petite voiture ne fût ce que enfin
une petite voiture utilitaire mais que
par contre puisse s'accomoder
formidablement de vivre dans une
mansarde affreuse 7e étage où j'ai une
amie urbanistes qui m'a dit que
l'acompte de nombre de familles
françaises qui n'ont pas de rester à
l'intérieur et quand même très très hot
ils sont le sens de l'udc en ce même pas
le confort est ce que la cuisine
française est bonne excellente
formidable c'est beaucoup mieux que tous
les autres que j'ai
oui elle est bonne seulement il faut la
similaires il m'a fallu du temps pour
m'habituer mais j'aime beaucoup oui une
des meilleures oui certainement le texan
est
[Musique]
ce qu'il ya un blague de préférer
notamment le steak au poivre l'a12
provençal j'aime beaucoup les crustacés
de steak frites et de vert rouge
moi j'aime bien les orties j'aime
beaucoup le foot
c'est tout simplement les eaux bonnes
femmes le bourguignon saiz et manger et
moi je leur donne raison
écouter les français mangent bien
non il y en a qui mange trop je m'en
voudrais de
la crise et je n'aimerais que pouvoir
faire romeu je pense qu'ils ont tendance
à manger de trop
ils mangent beaucoup plus grand atout
[Musique]